tu es d'abord ce qui s'est passé ce
matin 3 heures pour la santé c'était le
mot d'ordre lancé par les trois grandes
organisations syndicales cgt cfdt et
fédérations de l'éducation nationale en
association avec l'affect confédération
syndicale des médecins français
protestation contre le projet de
convention de la sécurité sociale tout
de suite des précisions sur cette
journée françois go et ce rassemblement
civique tfn dont l'objectif je vous le
rappelle est de s'opposer au projet de
convention médecin sécurité sociale
beaucoup de monde une ambiance plutôt
joyeuse à cause du soleil peut-être avec
aussi une importante consommation et
sandwich c'est l'heure du déjeuner ici
nous sommes sur l'esplanade de la tour
montparnasse à paris et les manifestants
attendent les allocutions des dirigeants
des trois centrales syndicales prévue
pour dans quelques minutes
ainsi d'ailleurs qu'une allocution d'un
dirigeant de la confédération des
syndicats médicaux français qui on le
sait participe elle aussi avec d'autres
organisations sociales à cette journée
nationale d'action
par ailleurs le parti communiste et le
parti socialiste apportent leur soutien
pour nous rarement nom aura assisté à
une telle levée de boucliers pour la
sécurité sociale
et puis il n'ya pas de paris il n'y a
pas que la capitale en province d'autres
rassemblements milieu ils doivent avoir
lieu aujourd'hui et tous sont
accompagnés de débrayage d'arrêt de
travail soit en fin de matinée soit en
début d'après midi avec des grèves qui
parfois atteint 24 heures
partout le thème est identique je cite
le projet de convention mettre en
sécurité sociale est inacceptable pour
les assurés sociaux comme pour les
médecins
il n'y aura pas de déficit à paris ce
rassemblement doit se disloquer à
quelques centaines de mètres ici presque
sous les fenêtres de l'immeuble qui
abrite le siège de la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie qui justement
aujourd'hui doit examiner le projet de
convention ici l'esplanade du lac tour
montparnasse à bouliac